Okay.
Um,
I took a sauna when I was in,
uh,
Germany and evidently they,
I heard that they were naked.
They go into those saunas naked and it's coed.
So I asked Verzi if you wanted to go down to the sauna.
He said yes.
And then I texted him,
he must've fell asleep.
So I said,
fuck it.
I went down,
I worked out,
got a great workout in,
and then I went to go into the sun and there was nobody in there.
And the old me,
I liked the steam.
Now I really liked the dry sauna because you can get way hotter.
You know,
Joe Rogan converted me,
right?
So I go in there and I went in there like an American,
I have my slippers on,
I had my towel on and all of that shit.
And then all of a sudden this dude comes walking in and he is a towel on.
I'm like,
oh,
thank God.
Thank God it's Berlin.
Okay,
Berlin.
this is like their New York City,
so everybody's going to act accordingly.
And then he just immediately takes his towel off and I'm like,
what the fuck?
So any lazy and then lays down.
Yeah.
What he did was he put his outside leg,
the leg close to me,
he put it up.
So he was sort of covering his junk,
slashed,
looked like he was getting ready to do,
recreate the Burt Reynolds
playgirl center full.
Right.
So anyways,
and I know this is going to be the fucking Photoshop.
So I'm sitting there,
I got,
what the fuck?
All right.
Whatever one naked dude who gives a shit.
Right?
And then all of a sudden another guy comes in,
this guy comes in,
he doesn't have his towel on.
He's just holding his towel in front of his junk.
Then he goes in like it was shaped like a horse shoe,
you know,
like the old fucking a Denver Bronco Stadium back in the day.
So I'm on one side of the horse shoe.
I'm on like the visitor's side.
The first naked dude is on the fucking home site and then this naked guy comes
in and he lays down the same way.
Same playgirl fucking thing with the outside leg up.
He's sitting in the end zone seats.
All right.
And I'm like Jesus fucking Christ.
So now I'm laughing cause all I'm thinking is I'm going to tell Versie cause at
this point it's just naked guys and just naked guys.
It's just funny.
I used to in my act and naked man is either funny or scary,
right?
If you're at a football game and a naked guy jumps out of the crowd and runs
across the field,
you're laughing your ass off.
If you're walking home late at night,
then naked guy jumps out of the fucking bushes.
It's one of the scariest things ever.
So this was just funny.
I'm in a gym,
there's all kinds of people around or whatever,
even though it's just the three of us in there.
But you know I can just get up,
walk out the fucking door.
There is no danger here.
There's two naked guys.
It's fucking hilarious.
So I'm looking down at the floor and all I'm thinking about is I can't wait to
tell version of this fucking story.
They both lane here and like fucking twin Burt Reynolds.
And I'm sitting here with my slippers on and my towel,
you know,
I dunno.
So anyways,
and then all of a sudden the door opens again and now a woman comes walking in
and I'm looking,
I kind of look at the guys like,
are they going to cover themselves up and they don't.
Then she comes in and just takes fucking towel off.
I'm just like,
what the fuck?
And then she sits down in the end zone seats.
All right,
so above her and the upper deck is this naked guy to her left is the other naked
guy.
She's naked anally.
She looks over at me and I got a towel on and slippers.
So now I'm looking like the Weirdo.
Now I'm the fucking pervert.
Like we're at this fucking guy.
We're all getting naked.
Why you sitting over there?
Right?
So now I'm like,
well,
I go to get the fuck outta here.
And just as I said that the dude in the home seat,
he stands up and he's going to walk out and I'm like,
all right,
perfect.
Now he's going to use the shower.
I'm just going to wait these stone with the shower.
Then I'm going to fucking walk up.
So that's exactly what happens.
I walk out,
but when I walk out,
what I forgot to mention was they had like,
you know those ice baths that like NFL players go to get into um,
bad,
something like that.
But it wasn't ice.
It was just like,
uh,
it was a tank.
You climbed up like six steps and then climbed down into this thing and it was
freezing fucking cold right after the sauna.
Right.
And just closes up all your pores.
It gets rid of all the fucking toxins and all of that.
All this shit washes off here.
Granted,
everybody else is using it.
So it's probably fucking gross in some level.
I have no idea.
Maybe because it's so cold.
It kills the shit.
I don't know what.
So I wanted to use it,
but there was no way I was going to use it because I had to get up to the top of
it and take my towel off and be standing up there with my fucking man who had
twisted in the breeze before I went down into the fucking Arctic water.
But when I came out there was nobody there.
So I was like,
I gotta,
I gotta try it.
So I fucking scampered up the ladder quickly,
took my towel off and then went down into it.
I was like,
fuck.
It was freezing cold when all the way up to like my neck and wanted to stay
there for a minute,
but probably only stayed there for like 15 seconds.
It was enough for me.
But plus also I knew other people are going to come in and I didn't want to come
crawling out of there completely naked.
Like fucking Jason Alexander now with my fucking junk all pulled up into me.
Right.
Oh,
the other dudes in the shower,
I could hear him.
So now I go to get out of this fucking thing.
I get my towel on and everything and I feel fucking amazing to go from that heat
to that call.
Now I'm going to go into the shower.
It was fucking amazing.
So again,
out of the shower,
now all I want to do is tell virtually the fucking story.
It'd be like,
dude,
even a chick came and this is fucking nuts.
And I reached into my robe and I can't find my key to my locker
and like where the fuck is it?
I drop it with and I'm looking all around and I was in last time I remembered
having it.
I was holding it in my hand when I was in the sauna because I didn't want to
leave it in the pocket of my robe for some reason I didn't see like the band
that you could put it around your wrist.
I just didn't,
you know,
I'm an idiot.
And I saw,
I was just holding onto it and I suddenly realized that it was still in the
fucking sauna.
So now I have to go back the sauna.
So I go back in there with my head down with my fucking slippers on and my towel
on and I go back in there and the naked woman is now laying down sideways facing
the door.
Okay.
Laying down where I was sitting and I'm like I can't go over there with my towel
on being like,
Hey,
I'm just looking for my keys.
All right there sweetheart.
Right.
It felt like a fucking Weirdo.
So now I sat down,
she sitting on the fucking visitor side,
now I'm on the home side or whatever.
I might have fucked up these things.
You know what I mean?
I'm sitting on the opposite side that I was sitting on
and now I'm just sitting there going,
all right,
well she was,
she's been in here for like 10 minutes.
She's going to fucking leave soon and when she does I'm going to look for my
keys and she just won't leave.
She won't leave.
And then finally I just have to get up cause I'm dying cause this is my second
trip in that I find when I say I'm sorry,
I think I left my key over here and she's like,
Oh I didn't see it.
And she's like sitting,
sitting up like fucking naked.
Right?
So now I go back over and I just fucking sit down.
No,
I fucked up the story.
I'm sitting down there going,
what the fuck do I do now?
Cause I'm dying of heat.
And then all of a sudden
this couple comes walking in and then they both get naked.
Now there's two naked women,
a naked dude and then me all covered up.
And at this point now I feel like a fucking Weirdo.
So I'm like,
Oh fuck it.
I'm in Germany.
So now I take my towel off and I'm just sitting there cracking up,
fucking laughing.
Like,
you know that you need just look down and you just,
you know what it's like,
I'm gonna laugh my ass off,
but nobody's going to know.
So you don't make a sound and you don't change your face.
You just have your mouth open and you just kind of go like,
I was literally doing that while I was so fucking hot,
I could feel my heartbeat in my ears.
So at some point it just got so hot and she wasn't leaving and she was like a
pro.
So I finally just got up and I just sorta had my towel cover myself and go,
I'm sorry,
I think I left my cue over.
And she goes,
oh,
I did not see it the boulevard.
And I go,
all right.
So then I went back and I sat down.
That's what I did.
That's when I sat down and then she got up and I was like still going.
He goes,
it's gotta be underneath her or something.
So I waited for her to leave.
I toughed it out and then I walk over there and I'm feeling around on the
fucking seats and shit and it's just not there.
And they have the slats and I'm like,
it probably fell down in between.
And now I'm going to have to walk out with just my towel and robe on and go back
to the front desk,
pay the fee,
and all of this shit.
So now I walk out of the Sauna,
I'm fucking almost passing out and to my left and my peripheral,
I see that woman again,
naked at the top of the fucking ladder to go into the ice bath.
I'm like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I gotta Outta here.
Right?
And as I'm walking away,
you know,
yeah,
he name is [inaudible].
You go shag.
I hear her yelling over to somebody and I'm like,
I know she's not talking to me.
And then she just goes,
then she switches to English and she goes,
did you find your key?
And I kinda half turned,
but they look at it and I go,
no,
I didn't.
And then she goes,
is this it?
And I realized,
I bet where I left it,
when I scampered up the ladder to go there,
I left it at the top,
the iceberg.
I go,
Oh yeah it is.
And then she stays at the top of the ladder and just,
you know,
kind of hands it and I walk over and literally her vagina is above me and I kind
of reach up like looking,
but not looking at
skill,
darkish shade.
But I was so fucked up,
I didn't even take a shower and I just walked out and I went to the locker room
and I went in there and I was like pouring sweat and everyone was looking at me
like,
well divided these shower off is all red like a tomato.
Um,
anyways.
And then I just,
I put my shit back on that and that,
there you go.
That's my German saunas story.
But I have,
I got to,
I do have to tell you this though,
if you completely naked in a sauna,
it,
it's even better.
It is even better.
It's fucking weird.
But you only can do it in a place if everybody's naked than it isn't weird.
It isn't weird.
And uh,
if you're worried that you're going to get a stiffy cause there's a naked woman
in there,
there's also no other naked men in there.
So it neutralizes it.
Not to mention it's hot as shit.
Like I don't think anybody has ever fucked in one of those hot naked,
um,
you know,
the not naked,
the hot yoga class,
what do they call that?
The Bikram Yoga.
Like you can barely survive.
Fucking somebody is the last thing on your mind when you're sitting in like 180
degree heat.
But,
uh,
anyways,
there's my,
um,
that was my son a story.
It was hilarious.
I was worried that my junk was going to look too small when I got into the ice
bath and I was worried that I was going to fucking salute the Germans when I was
in the sauna.
If I,
th I,
I would,
you know,
if a naked woman walked in,
but it didn't,
I just felt like a fucking creep.
Um,
so anyways,
and that's why you travel the world,
everybody,
to get stories like that.